[Musik]
sport.ch live
warum sich zwar an berufen jetzt wollte
ich mein abi studieren
die stadt stockach ich wollte ja ich
habe ich kein problem gehört instagram
komischen film blog-leser luca ich meine
das ist auch entspannt bei dir einfach
mal so auf druck doch sein handy und
sieht ba 10 verpasste anrufe von manager
geht ja das telefon gesagt werde nicht
einmal angerufen aber er wollte was geht
ab blut schuhe ich hoffe ja bisher
wunderschönen tag eher wie ich zehnmal
alle rufen statt das hat mittlerweile
jeder verstanden graf wie geht's dir
heute morgen so bis es ist schön dass du
das ist schön dass du so schön und gut
geschlafen heißt also ich das habe ich
gehört heute nach viele meinten hey luca
dafür dass du denn es immer diese
sportgeräte stehen das basteln und
liebig nicht drauf dann mache ich
erstmal morgensport wohne frau meine
damen und herren das erste mal gewesen
war
ich muss sagen das training ist jetzt
auch vorbei sorgte war sehr gut übrigens
ist es nicht so dass ich hier diese
spiderman t shirt aber bevor das noch
irgendeiner sagt dann ist dich jetzt
dass er erst mal an nur dass es weiter
mit dem lokal gerade im schrank oben ich
gehe jetzt erst mal was essen zu joghurt
mit obstsalat und müsli
das ist gesund tolle rallye dakar ich
bekomme häufig kommentare von wegen hey
lokale sachen die du gegen die mit einem
handy macht sie kann auch auf kuba
nehmen so es gibt ja diesen werbespot in
die hügel und dann sagt irgendwas
zeigt das wetter oder in sonnencremes
deswegen würde ich sagen ich teste dass
es einfach mal mit meinem google gerät
und zwar hält google wie wird das wetter
heute wenn dich das wetter sieht wird es
directly anfangen zu regnen in der daten
danke dafür an scheint funktioniert mein
google bewegt euch so richtig weil
draussen scheint auf jeden fall gerade
die sonne vielleicht liegt es einfach
daran dass es bei google gerät und nicht
wirklich konfiguriert habe also hey
google speicher mich bitte unter luka du
bist ab sofort abgespeichert als 13 ja
ich lebe hier für jeden fall erstmal
kurz da draußen die sonne und hoffe dass
sie nicht einschlafen werde
es ist 543 ich habe gerade zwei stunden
gesperrt
draußen irgendwie ist das alles ein
zeichen dafür dass sie nach zu wenig
schlaf wir hier jetzt erstmal duschen
vielleicht wenn ich danach bitter war
noch nicht richtig fit da die dusche
nicht wirklich geholfen hat dass sie
nochmal mit deutschland wieder fit
werden würde ich sagen ich frage erst
einmal meinen freund google also ok was
kann man dagegen tun da noch ein
mittagsschlaf nicht mehr so richtig
schneide jetzt erst mal ganz kurz den
block rahmen den wir quasi vorgestern
gewesen
es ist mit leute straße 43 ich habe aber
gerade eine heilige nachrichte heute
morgen passiert ist das krass ist also
sogar noch jetzt in diesem block a safe
dran weil ich habe gerade hatte
nachricht von einem kontaktmann bei
porsche bekommen porsche automobil
hersteller sollte man eigentlich kennt
was ich für fahrzeuge interessiert bzw
wenn man überhaupt einfach nur ein
mensch ist könnt ihr euch auch daran
erinnern ich hatte ck von einem jahr mal
bekamen von dem bekommen zum porsche
gehabt damals wo ich zum hockenheimring
hingefahren bin der ansicht von porsche
wohl mensch der immer seinen kleinen
süßen minimum gegeben dem einfach eine
neue karte für sich
haben wir schon mal jubeln eine davon
wäre das auf jeden fall bekomme ich
morgens bitte das übrigens nicht
sponsern von porsche die bezahl nicht
für gar nix ich bekomme kein geld ich
muss nicht sagen ich kann das an die
marke ist blöd aber ich mag porsche auf
jeden fall bekomme ich morgen mittag
einen 911 carrera gts als cabrio hier
vorbei gebracht
ich freu mich gefreut als ich jetzt
nicht auskennen mit autos und jetzt
nicht wissen ob er ist hat die karre das
bedeutet dieses geht es überhaupt
und so weiter und so fort dann kann ich
euch jetzt mal einfach den sound von dem
fahrzeug nachstellen
nehmen wir an ich mache jetzt ein launch
control staat also das ist wenn man mit
dem linken fuß auf die bremse geben im
rechten fuß aufs gas
der drehzahlmesser dreht hoch und wenn
man dann den linken fuß hoch nimmt wird
das fahrzeug was sie freigelassen und
schnell nach vorne da hört sich das so
an als wenn man beide füße drauf hat
also auch noch den linken fuß auf der
bremse ist dass regionen in denen in den
in den in den in den ländern in denen
bei der fahrzeughalle freigelassen
werden will und wäre nicht den sound
islam mache zeige ich euch mal was ich
mit den beiden händen mache also das
hier ist gas und das hier ist bremse das
heißt gleich geh ich hoch
das wird spaßig und als wäre das noch
nicht genug wäre ich morgen tatsächlich
mit der karte erst mal nach hannover zu
lukas ist ein freund von mir und das
wird heute das mit löw das wird auf
jeden fall mache ich mir jetzt erst mal
was zu essen mensch wer jetzt gedacht
ich fett sagt familie irgendeiner da
wesentlich wunder das ist jetzt schon
dunkel ist habe ich musste das dinner
hochladen das wird doch schon langsam
der winter also die sonne geht ja
darunter blabla wie ich mache mir jetzt
auf jeden fall etwas zu essen und schon
gar
[Musik]
wenn ich den kopf nicht raus chinesische
reifen warm machen das ganze was ist
daran hier unten und probieren ob das
ganze schon einigermaßen warm geworden
ist ich denke wir uns registriert wo ich
se hat man essen und plötzlich taucht
hier diese fliege auf aber die kann
irgendwie nicht mehr fliegen
normalerweise haben wir so fleck so dass
wenn man hier ist dass die irgendwie weg
fliegt oder so aber die hier irgendwie
nicht welche ist ein bereits aus einigen
anderen blogs nicht hochgeladen habe
immer als ich fliege auch bei mir die
wohnung in köln verehrt haben habe ich
tatsächlich immer aus dem fenster
geschmissen weil sie so brutal an aber
ich wollte dass die weiterleben deswegen
kleiner mann bitte einmal still halten
und nicht bewegen kommt jetzt wieder
nach draußen zu deinen freunden
da ist die kleine fliege also ich weiß
jetzt nicht wie du wieder gesund werden
kannst ich bin halt keine fliege aber
ich wünsche noch ein ganz tolles leben
und ich glaube drauf und das ist erst
mal glücklich hier drinnen menschen ich
bin sondern und jetzt bin ich im urwald
oder einfach hinter einer plastik
pflanze das bin ich meinen menschenalter
wir sind wieder zurück in der
vollidioten hauptzentrale die leute an
die kommentare geschrieben immer wieder
werden mit lucky machen hier mit dem
kleinen genau mit ihr soll ich auf jeden
fall mit du kannst gerade nicht wirklich
halte ich in der hand die leute meint in
den kommentaren hey mach doch mal wer
mit love i was denn
also schreibt mir die kommentare und ich
unterhalte mich ja schon relativ häufig
in die wiese solches zeug das ist mein
klo
wenn du keine kamera hast
[Musik]
das war das schöne an dieser stelle
würde ich jetzt allerdings auch sagen
dass wir uns dann morgen wieder sehen
bei morgan wirklich eine menge passieren
[Musik]
wo kann ich nicht von anderen welcher
tore haben guten morgen lupe was geht da
habe ich hoffe ihr tag beginnt mit einem
tollen basler aber ich will für eine
scheiße und erstmal schön den vorhang
hierauf machen einen schönen guten
morgen das ist natürlich das erste dass
man da erst mal schön in den garten
reingucken das hat dieser vorwochenende
äußert ist ein guter tag bei der damen
und herren uns mal bekomme ich gleich
von porsche einen ich gestern schon
gesagt also in diesem gleichen block ja
eigentlich auch schon ich bekomme gleich
von porsche einen sportwagen fußläufig
bekommen gleich neun elf und porsche
hier weil du keinen kontakt zu den hass
und deren der ist für mich du hast nicht
mein führerschein und auto hatte ich die
ganze zeit sonst bin ich immer
unpünktlich aber die meisten anderen
freundlich
freunde der neuen elbe bei mir abgegeben
und bei der die farbe ist lara orange
gibt euch dieses habe freunde das ist
jetzt nur das fahrzeug also von denen
hier alles alcantara hier alles
alcantara sitzt und so weiter und so
fort tempel carpendale verbunden das
jetzt also die mittelkonsole ist porsche
pdk doppelkupplungsgetriebe ich hätte
noch ganz gern als schalt wagen gehabt
aber kann man nichts machen ja was kann
ich noch sagen ich glaube dass es
unserem einen haupt zu schauen jetzt
siehst du die ultra autobegeisterten
personen sind als in dem anderen blogger
sehen wollte wie ich die caritas ist ein
bisschen beschreiben so sagen dass es so
ist dann sagt man mir gerne in den
kommentaren bescheid aber was sie
eigentlich erst mal wissen was das ist
neues dts - im jahr 2017 450 ps
newtonmeter kenne ich jetzt gar nicht
auswendig aber ich kann euch mal im
motor stone zeigen und zwar
schon jetzt also ich könnte jetzt noch
in den sportmodus gehen dann hörte er
die das klappern dieses am ende ich
kenne jetzt auch nicht so aus aber das
ist meine ich einfach nur benzin was
überflüssig ist und quasi explodiert
oder verbrennen und das finde ich ein
bisschen mechanisch in die also ich
finde schöner wenn das dieser
ursprünglichen sound von motors auf
jeden fall bin ich jetzt gerade bei
meiner oma angekommen weil mein cousin
auch hier ist und er wollte die cara
auch mal sehen übrigens ist ja auch noch
die keramikbremsanlage verbaut also wenn
man bremst dann steht man mehr oder
weniger die medien gebt euch diese karte
alter wie kann ein auto so porno mäßig
sein
das war jetzt gerade erst mal die
reaktion vom helm cousin auf dieses auto
ein zuhause ich will wieder zu hause
angekommen und eigentlich wollte ich mit
meinem dad eine runde drehen mit dem
porsche weil er auch ein ganz großer fan
von ist und jetzt hat er gerade gesagt
dass er die carat erstmal die garage
fahren wollte doch jetzt ist das schon
seit einer halben stunde mit dem auto
weg also auf jeden vergangen an der
schule papa das sein kann mein auto
klaus aber jetzt zu langweilig habe ich
mit der zeit einfach mal was zu essen
gemacht ich hätte tag
das war aber nicht nur einfach in die
garage fahren ich befinde mich im auto
und fahrrad zu lukas also bielefeld ist
ja eine stunde 15 zähler davon entfernt
das heißt ihr seht ihr jetzt paar coole
aufnahmen
[Musik]
ich bin jetzt jeden moment da ja okay
was ich bin jetzt angekommen bei laser
luca und wie sollte es anders sein
freunde fluffy ist auch mit am start und
hat sogar seine sonnenbrille mitgebracht
aber irgendwie steht ihm nicht so
richtig
[Musik]
blogger jährige wir haben jetzt hunger
oder um genau zu sein
lukas hat noch mal deswegen gefragt
waren wir einfach zu merken
die fina hat noch keinen namen hatte du
hast gerade also schreibt jetzt alle
namen die kommentare wie dieser delfin
hier also soll ich bin für flipper und
lukas bisher ist hannover tatsächlich
nicht so die aller geilste stadt muss
ich sagen komm ada freunde das sind
vollidioten
wir sind jetzt gerade zu den mcdonald's
gegangen und ich hätte das vielleicht so
immer wenn man sich damit von tina
geholt oder pumpels man nimmt eigentlich
90 prozent aller menschen würde ich
jetzt mal so sagen nehmen sie es nicht
geht also hin lukas hat sie mir gesagt
es gibt keine saison so macdonald hat
keine chance mehr
grossmann noch und irgendwie komme ich
gerade auch wieder alles mögliche zu
kaufen was noch offen obwohl ich jetzt
einfach gerade nicht in köln sondern
hier könnt ihr mir leid
auch heinz richter bio menschen hannover
ist ja keine ahnung es gibt locker
irgendwelche schönen gegenden hier aber
gegen die da wo wir jetzt alle sind es
irgendwie nicht so leicht weil ich halt
auch mit ihm unterwegs beladen instagram
einstige laser luca hahaha ich dachte
was blogger und der verlierer ist der
fällen dreimal dürft ihr raten welcher
vollidiot kaugummi beck gespuckt hat und
wo befindet sich jetzt in den nuggets
spaß dann verständig den heutigen blog
jetzt allerdings auch beendet ist jetzt
gerade irgendwie schon drei und nachts
werden noch bis in vier folgen spielt
bisschen gelabert und so war ich hatte
diese blog gefallen
mit dem auto ist für waren für mich ein
sehr schöner block war das auto selbst
wenn euch dieser block gefallen
natürlich nicht selber einen like von
euch freuen also lasst ein leichter weil
dann würde ich mich freuen und sonst
würde ich jetzt sagen sie wir uns morgen
mit dem glauben heißt der beste blocker
der welt nach deinen neuen blog
versuchen 3
[Musik]